maría y carlos ordenaron una pizza un
refresco de un litro y como postre una
barra de chocolate como tendrán que
dividirlo para que les toquen partes
iguales
carlos comenzó por dividir la pizza en
dos que es lo mismo que un medio
entonces a cada uno le toca un medio de
pizza a los pocos minutos llegaron sus
papas y también querían pizza así que
dividieron la pizza en cuatro aunque a
maría ya carlos les tocará menos pizza
todos comerán la misma cantidad
su papá servirá el refresco pero como
crees que lo dividirá si es un líquido
pausa el vídeo e intenta resolver no te
olvides de reproducirlo otra vez para
conocer la solución veamos tenemos un
litro de refresco que hay que repartir
en cuatro partes iguales lo repartirá en
un vaso y cada vaso representa un cuarto
del refresco entonces cada uno tomará un
cuarto de refresco
después de terminar con la pizza y el
refresco repartirá en el chocolate que
ya está dividido en ocho partes iguales
cada una de estas partes equivale a un
octavo ya viste a simple vista podemos
apreciar que les tocaran dos pedazos de
chocolate a cada quien pero cómo podemos
representarlo en fracciones cada uno se
comerá dos octavos pero la mamá de maría
y carlos solo se comió la mitad de lo
que le tocó cuánto fue lo que se comió
se comió un octavo te habías imaginado
que usas fracciones todos los días con
algo tan común como comer una pizza o un
chocolate sigue practicando